what's the difference between bitcoin
and doge so there are two main
really important differences which you
must remember so the first and most
important
is that bitcoin has a limited supply
there will only ever be
21 million bitcoin no more can be
created
no more can be printed this is really
important doge
doesn't have a limited supply it has an
unlimited supply
10 000 new doge coins are created every
single minute this is actually more than
million coins a day this makes doge a
inflationary asset which means the value
of it is likely to go down
over time and the second point is
decentralization bitcoin is a
decentralized network dojo on the other
hand is not decentralized the majority
of the coins are held in only around 10
to 11 wallets
that can cause huge market manipulation
meaning those holders can dump on the
market whenever they want